in spring we move our clocks forward an
hour and in fall we move them back an
hour that's section in between we call
that daylight savings time and oh it's
singular sorry
I mean daylight saving time it may seem
pretty straightforward but daylight
saving time has both serious
repercussions and major benefits in the
United States of America
48 states observe daylight saving time
with Hawaii most of Arizona and the US
territories of Guam American Samoa
Puerto Rico and the US Virgin Islands
choosing to ignore it in spring the 48
states all jump ahead an hour and the
immediate effects can be disastrous one
study found that the average American
worker loses 40 minutes of sleep when
the clock Springs forward that means
lots of people could be losing an hour
of sleep or more on the same night
essentially giving us all jetlag and
sleep deprivation can lead to serious
health issues according to studies the
first Monday of daylight saving time has
25 percent more heart attacks than a
typical Monday car accidents go up 17%
in the days after time shift workplace
accidents go up about 6% workers are 67
percent more likely to miss work due to
these accidents productivity goes way
down the first Monday after daylight
saving time daylight saving time isn't
even Universal fewer than half of the
countries in the world actually use it
and few agree on when it starts or ends
the switch to daylight savings time has
a lot of negatives so why do we do it at
all the real reason we kept daylight
saving time and extended it economics
some studies suggest we spend money when
it's sunny outside if it's light out
after work or school people spend more
at the shops from 1968 to 1971 the UK
kept their version of daylight savings
time for the whole year and traffic
deaths decline by 11 percent because it
was light after work during the winter
another recent study found that kids are
more likely to exercise
as outside during the winter daylight
saving time rather than huddling inside
after school with benefits and negative
effects
it's no wonder daylight saving time has
opponents and supporters but on what
side of the clock do you stand